a couple weeks ago you tweeted something
out then yeah i'm bring it up okay that
got a
crazy amount of attention
which
did it sports illustrated swimsuit
edition i believe you're referring to
yes
i tweeted out sorry
not beautiful
[Music]
hello and welcome to episode 150
of my podcast i'm michaela peterson like
i said this is my 150th episode and i
had the pleasure of having my dad on
to discuss all sorts of fun things the
first time in over a year he's been on
my podcast we discussed the twitter
drama over his comments on the sports
illustrated swimsuit cover
connections between personality types
and gender and romantic relationships we
covered a lot that would make some
people angry i really hope you enjoyed
this episode i certainly did thank you
to all who supported me on the way to
recording 150 of these it's just insane
wouldn't have been possible without you
guys
this episode was brought to you by
rabbit air i am relocating from
nashville
i'm moving to miami i'm doing it the
tree allergies are too awful here i
tried moving from franklin to nashville
that didn't help enough so i just have
to escape tennessee
it might sound like i'm being crazy but
i'm not the tree allergies here are
insane and scarlet has them too and
she's not sleeping well so that brings
me to rabbit air i think i would have
just died here if i didn't have my
rabbit air filter if you have trouble
getting quality sleep or even if you
sleep fine it's worth getting an air
filter to see if it improves your life
particularly if you have environmental
allergies or pets or live in an old
house
i have one of these in the office as you
can see
a gorgeous cover if i do say so myself
you can design them how you like uh i
have one in my bedroom too i do think
you'll love rabbit air's award-winning
purifiers i had this
horrifying hunk of junk air purifier
when i was a kid that my mom bought me
that made me feel like more of a nerd
than i am rabbit air is top of the line
they're extremely quiet and super easy
to clean even if you have no issues
sleeping we still breathe in nearly 2
000 gallons of air a day americans spend
around 90 percent of their time indoors
which is pathetic where the air is two
to five times more polluted this
includes bacteria pet dander dust
particles fumes mold pollen rabbit air's
state-of-the-art filter design reduces
bacterial growth and viruses too
put one in your kid's room get one of
these and stick them anywhere they're
quiet they look good and they make your
place cleaner and your air better it's
kind of a no-brainer in my opinion
do yourself a favor and visit
rabbitair.com today they have a
five-year warranty free shipping and
returns plus a 90-day money-back
guarantee on all their products that's
r-a-b-b-i-t-a-r-dot-com
for some of the best air purifiers
you'll find no matter where you look
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoy this episode
[Music]
welcome to my podcast ad hi nick
i haven't done a podcast with you in a
very long time
how long do you know
year yeah
over a year yeah over a year
still in toronto yeah in my podcast
studio and now i just have a studio
in a different hotel all the time right
yeah hopefully one day that will be more
organized
um i'm nearing my 150th episode oh
are we going to do this for your 150th
episode oh i guess we have to now i
guess you
put your foot in it there
uh before we get started
um how have you been
much better yeah
yeah i'm doing better than i have been
for
five years probably five years that's
good at least i think the last time we
did a podcast we was
yeah
it was pretty rough
it was pretty rough
but we're out of it seemed to be out of
it we'll see you're looking pretty sharp
at the moment good thank you yeah i
don't think i've seen this suit before
not on your podcast never on my podcast
yes it looks good it's definitely been a
tour suit
yeah it's very non-wrinkly so it's a
good travel suit you can stuff it
anywhere and it works that's this is
exactly it stuffable yes i was on the
beach with it this morning for a photo
shoot of all the absurd things with it
hiked up to my knees in the water with
my three-piece suit that's
that's hilarious yeah joe model
okay you say that but
we went to we were at a black tie event
i think and i was just standing there
and you're like no you got to put your
foot forward so don't act like you don't
know how to pose because you are very
good at posing oh thank you yeah my
whole life is the pose or so my enemies
say
what's he doing what's his game what
role is he playing
it's like
i'm saying what i think
that's a role yeah that's like that's
what you think
saying what you think and
modeling three-piece suits in the ocean
yeah exactly exactly
that was the destiny i always presumed
would would make itself manifest
that's great
okay so i thought
what people might find useful for this
episode i'm going to ask you for advice
on a number of topics i think people
will find helpful yeah and
maybe delve a little bit into gender
differences just to keep things spicy
keep some people out there angry yeah
yeah because i don't think i've
irritated like a million people for at
least a week exactly so it's definitely
time to say something you know
outrageous
or slash true
outrageous slash true yeah how did you
feel let's start with this actually a
couple weeks ago you tweeted something
out
yeah um bring it up okay that got a
crazy amount of attention
which
did it sports illustrated swimsuit
edition i believe you're referring to
yes
i tweeted out sorry
not beautiful
yeah people were very happy with that
and then everyone got upset yes they did
and then i left twitter again more or
less right after that and
everyone assumed that that was why and
it actually it wasn't
now
it was it was i suppose in some sense it
was because what happened was an
indication of
the problem with twitter but i had been
not reading
twitter comments for about three weeks
although i had been
tweeting through an intermediary one of
my staff members so i'd email him a
tweet but not reading comments because i
found that quite
um irksome yeah you're associating with
the
devil
sure yeah exactly yeah that was like
sort of like standing in a public park
where anybody no matter who they were
could come up and yell at you
to any size audience about anything they
wanted day or night
and so
uh i've been thinking that through i'm
gonna write an article about what's
wrong with twitter and social media in
general but um
no i looked at this sports illustrated
cover
and they had a
uh
rather
overweight young woman quite symmetrical
so nice facial features and so forth
um
with a very revealing swimsuit on the
cover
and i thought
no
like and not
not in a personal way but
it's unbelievably manipulative for about
three different reasons the first is
it's a very tawdry attempt to capitalize
on cheap sales
that's and i mean cheap in a specific
way sports illustrated hit the gold mine
with their swimsuit cover i suppose 20
years ago whenever they established that
because it was obviously it's a sports
magazine so it's about athletics it's
about athletic people it's about
athletic bodies and they had a swimsuit
issue and it really was a big hit and
then it became kind of a cultural icon
and it's a very specific kind of
cultural icon because it
focuses on
a very exceptional kind of high-end
beauty
and so that beauty would involve
symmetry and signals of youth because
that's part of
beauty sexual beauty
physical beauty um waist to hip ratio
for women but with
sports illustrated it's also
highlighting a kind of athleticism in
body type
and that's a very specific form of
beauty you have to be young you have to
be female generally you have to be
extremely athletic you have to be
shapely in a very particular way and
that would be with the waist-to-hip
ratio of 0.68 because that's what's
being established cross-culturally as
ideal from the perspective of
male
sexual interest let's say but that's
also associated with fertility
um and so it's a marker that has a
biological basis and so
even if you're a very beautiful woman
you're you're hard-pressed to be
beautiful enough to be on the cover of
sports illustrated for the swimsuit
issue and so it's a very it's a pinnacle
achievement of sorts
and it's focused on a very idealized and
specific form of beauty and that's
obviously
exclusionary it's obviously exclusionary
it excludes
everyone right and and it does that to
highlight a kind of ideal and that's
a particular ideal of beauty and there
are some cultural boundaries around that
so you could say well it's a westernized
form of beauty it's like yeah and you
can point to reuben's paintings of
more plump women and say well there's an
exception it's like great you think
you're a genius for finding that
exception good for you you know the
reuben's painting like more power to you
but that doesn't mean anything at all
about the universality of images of
beauty and
so the cul the cover bothered me a lot
because it was a cheap manipulation of
something that had been working very
well for sports illustrated it was also
an insistence that all of a sudden this
non-athletic body type
is
as beautiful as the standard
swimsuit
model for sports illustrated and
it's not it's not as athletic and it's
not as healthy and that's that and it's
also not arbitrary and so the whole
thing is a lie and then it's a lie
that's a manipulation of that young
woman
now she partakes in that because she
participates in it but it's still
they're not on her side they're
exploiting her as far as i'm concerned
and she may be participating in that
exploitation but they're still
exploiting her so don't pull any moral
stunts on me because you're irritated
about my opinion about the sports
illustrated cover when it's bloody clear
to anybody with eyes that that was
manipulative in 20 different ways
and so and i'm also not willing to
sacrifice these ideals
for inclusiveness it's like no not
everyone's a genius
no not everyone's picasso
no not everyone's young and healthy and
no
not everyone is a sports illustrated
swimsuit model period and [ __ ] you if
you don't like it
so that's basically
what i thought about that i certainly
didn't think it would cause as much
trouble as it did you know when people
were on my case for being mean it's like
yeah i know i'm always mean because
you know that's
well also like life is hard and like
life is mean right and it's hard for
people first first of all i have great
sympathy for anybody overweight because
of the health struggles i went through
and you lost a whole bunch of weight
it's not like being overweight is fun
right that's a whole other problem to
get into with um i think people have
such an issue losing weight yeah that
society has said you know what it's fine
because because you've had so much
trouble it's that it's probably your
genetics so well there's truth in that
like when i look at someone who's obese
on the street i think
oh that's too bad like that's too bad i
i don't think you know
obese pig eats too much has no self
control i don't think that i think
uh bad mismatch between genetic
proclivity and
appalling diet and the appalling diet is
basically we're not going to get into
this
but basically carbohydrate heavy and
sugar loaded and fair enough you know we
try to hard the whole world to make
calories cheap and we did that we did so
no one's starving and great but now we
have an obesity problem and it's a major
problem and i'm not going to pretend
that it's okay it's not okay that
doesn't mean i don't have sympathy for
it and i'm not willing to sacrifice any
ideals for this idiot inclusiveness i'm
done with that and so should everyone
else be and most i think most people are
and they look at that cover and they
know it's manipulative and
and a lie in a deep sense
but then if you point that out and this
is where we're at in the culture there's
all sorts of things now if you point to
and you say you know
that's a lie
people get upset it's like no that's a
lie you're just that's not a lie you're
just being mean we're just being nice
yeah 1994. yeah yeah yeah
no it's a lie yeah it's like here's
another lie
every 10 year old knows what gender they
are and that's so fixed
that
surgical intervention may well be
necessary and it's illegal for you to
suggest otherwise however
your gender identity is so fluid that
you can change it every hour if you want
and it's not fixed at all
and it's and it's infinitely variable at
your whim
okay
i'm supposed to accept all of that am i
every single bit of that set of
propositions even though they're
entirely internally contradictory which
means it's actually impossible for me to
accept all of those propositions and to
stay sane
well yeah but if you don't you're mean
it's like you're a predator well that
brings something else i want to talk to
you about i've been thinking about this
a fair bit i talked to friends to wall
primatologist genius primatologist in my
estimation and i don't know if there's a
nobel prize that would be specifically
appropriate for france to wall but he if
there was a nobel prize for the sort of
science he's doing
he would deserve it because he's
discovered things that are really
they're unbelievably fundamental for
example he's discovered that
sometimes in chimp troops the smallest
male is the alpha
really yeah that it's not dependent on
power a small
a smaller chimp
can be alpha for example if he has the
support of one of the older females who
has
strong kin connections within the troop
but also is a sophisticated social actor
and i don't mean manipulator and i don't
mean dominator because dewalt has
established very very clearly and this
is signally important work that
status and authority in a chimp troop
and that is associated with reproductive
success is much more dependent on
the ability to reconcile
and the ability to maintain reciprocal
positive relationships with multiple
individuals far more dependent on that
than on the expression of physical power
so this is crucially important and
dewalt just wrote a new book i think
it's called differences where he
outlined
sex differences in
toy preference behavioral preference
differences between male and female
chimps especially juveniles so the
females for example if you give a female
chimp a block of wood you know a reason
of the appropriate size she will carry
it around like a infant so she makes a
block of wood into a doll
if you give her a doll a teddy bear or
something like that that's definitely
instantly an infant and she will take
care of it and she'll share it with the
other chimps that she trusts and she'll
get hyper upset if they do anything to
it that you wouldn't do to an infant
whereas if you give a doll to a male
juvenile or a group of males yeah you
make a face they tear it apart see
what's inside of it
yeah and that's and that's funny because
that's
that you know that that's kind of the
stereotype for what a young boy might do
yeah so let's take a part and see what's
inside of it yeah well there's a hunting
devouring element of that but there's
also a gadget like curiosity yeah and
there's good work on chimps showing that
oddly enough the male juveniles if you
give them cars or like toy cars or dolls
they'll take the cars which is pretty
damn weird because it's not like chimps
have cars they have infants but they
don't have they are i guess they roll
well it's more fun well it probably has
something to do with tool use preference
is that they're more gadget oriented
even chimps because they do use tools to
some degree
um or maybe it's just that they're not
maternal yeah right so it's just the
other thing it's yeah it might be that
and i don't think the work on on that
preference is developed enough to be
sure but we do know that
likewise in human beings the biggest
difference that we know of between men
and women
um is their interest in people versus
things
and so but i was really struck by the
the carrying around of the wood block
the infantilization of the wood block
and that made me think because i have
been reading
putting two weird ideas together i've
been reading this
guide to a faculty retreat that mount
royal university in calgary had
published and i'd read and
it was just it was such an appalling
document so
there's very few things in life that are
less dangerous than going to a faculty
retreat at a college
like the the faculty don't bring axes
and pitchforks and they're not vikings
and they're not cannibals and they don't
devour each other and the probability of
getting in a fist fight is like zero or
lower and
they're just not dangerous in any
they're no they're as safe as any social
event could possibly be made with like
250 000 years of civilized effort and
yet the guide that the college published
indicated quite clearly that trained
counselors would be on hand just in case
just in case the discussion got too
intense and i thought
this is written by
edible mothers for kindergarteners and i
was thinking about that in relation to
wall's work and and into the broader
culture war that we're knee-deep in neck
deep in
forehead deep in maybe
um so here's a hypothesis
imagine that there's a default
ethos
that governs
what constitutes the basis for an
appropriate social relationship
whether it's an intimate relationship a
friendship
a relationship with your family members
or relationship with people in the
broader community imagine that there's
an ethos a way of interacting that would
characterize optimality across all those
domains simultaneously
one female default is
you're either an infant
or you're a caregiver
or you're a predator
and i think a lot of that's playing out
in the world now now but what cr where
does that come from
well i think it comes from the the
fundamental ethos that governs mother
infant bonding
i mean look
one of the
one of the issues that
women
and female chimps for that matter
struggle with
terribly is the lengthy period of
dependency that
highly intelligent primate infants
are characterized by and so
female chimp will carry her infant 500
miles
in in the first three years
she has to carry the infant they can
cling to but she has to carry the infant
everywhere it's an unbelievable burden
it's an unbelievable burden
and so
and it's partly because it's worse even
in human in humans because human infants
are born even less
able than chimpanzee infants and there's
a reason for that it's like a noodle
yeah well
they're like a fetus
they're actually they're actually fetal
in in a very real sense so
the human cortex is so large that
there's an arms race between the size of
the infant's head and the
the width of the pelvic opening through
which birth must take place
and
it's an it's a very difficult
balance to optimize if women's hips were
any wider which would make the pelvic
hole larger they couldn't run well so it
would interfere with the running which
obviously isn't so good if you're
running away from a predator if it was
smaller then the baby would have to be
born with a smaller brain or more
immature
the
the gestation period for a mammal of our
size
should it be if you
compared us to other
animals be two years yeah so our infants
are born
a year and three months premature and so
they're they're just
absolutely 100
helpless and so then there's an ethos
that has to govern your interaction with
the infant let's say up till about nine
months when they start to become
somewhat ambulatory so pre-ambulatory
infant is a different creature than an
infant who has the capacity to move
around in the world by the way the fear
circuitry in an infant doesn't really
kick in until they're ambulatory so
they're quite different from a
motivational perspective too before
they're
uh before they can move well why be
afraid if you can't move fears freezes
you if you can't move
you don't need fear because you can't
move yeah okay and so that's also yeah
that's also when they first show the
signs of stranger aversion and some
beginning fear of of the dark although
they do freak out if they're little and
you put them in somebody else's arms
yeah but but it doesn't look like it's
fear often that's pain a pain-like
response or anger
it's commonly anger it does look like
anger well
if they turn red
it's like when you watch someone who
cries in an argument is like i'm hurt
it's like no you're red you're mad
you're using you just say you're hurt
because that's a guilt weapon that angry
people use that doesn't happen all the
time no it doesn't i think that women
also get blamed for that sometimes when
it doesn't happen it's like especially
by men because they don't understand it
which is why are you crying and are you
trying to manipulate me yeah and
what i learned about was uh women's
tears actually
um
the smell of women's tears gave off a
pain response in men
do you know that no yeah yeah there's a
chemical in women's tears that give off
a pain see that's just how manipulative
it is
sometimes i'll show you here's some pain
i think sometimes when i so i know this
i don't cry very easily but if i'm
stressed already and then i get into an
argument
sometimes it'll happen i have to be
pretty stressed and i know some people
who will cry a lot easier they'll just
cry like
a lot of that had to do with being ill
yeah a lot of that did have to do with
it and i cry easier when i'm ill too so
that's understandable but um i think
women get blamed a lot of the time and i
don't think it's always manipulative no
that's true i don't think it's always
manipulative either not like
it might be a evolutionary response too
to when things get to a certain point
and you're getting some danger vibes as
a woman danger vibes that's what i'm
going to call them danger vibes that
you're more likely to yeah to cry so
that it's like don't hurt me kind of
thing yes it's an appeal to that's right
it's an appeal to the latent maternal
instinct within whoever you might be
interacting with but also that crying is
also it's a signal that the situation
has gone beyond your control yeah well
that's what children do they cry well
why because the cry attracts attention
and a child's cry we had a cat at one
point
um when i was a college student and uh
my roommate used to bring his little
niece over now and then and
if she cried the cat who was a female
cat would immediately come running over
and investigating so that that cry is a
mammalian constant and it means
something well it means something like
there may be a predator in the
environment sounds like an alarm
especially when they're really little
yeah definitely definitely so okay so
back to the female ethos well
i think that women
i think women's temperaments are
optimized
at least in part for the
mother
dependent infant dyad and the reason i
think that is because boys and girls
don't seem to be different in trait
neuroticism
and they're
little boys right before puberty
the difference kicks in at puberty and
so and so then women are more sensitive
to negative emotion and they stay that
way permanently
and it's quite a difference half a
standard deviation which is quite a
large difference it's it's enough so
that if you drew two random people from
the population one man man and one woman
and you had to guess who experienced
more negative emotion on average if you
guessed the woman you'd be right 60
percent of the time so it's not a huge
difference but it's not nothing and it
does kick in at puberty and so then the
question would be well why a puberty and
some answers are well males and females
become dimorphic at
puberties the boys get bigger and
stronger especially in terms of upper
body strength so they can start to win
physical combats physical combat not in
2022 though well
but but generally it doesn't take much
of a size advantage to prevail in a
physical
fight and so so that means physical
fighting starts to become more dangerous
for women when they hit puberty
especially in relationship to men but
then they also become sexually
vulnerable which is a huge
risk and so why wouldn't you be more
threat sensitive because of that and
then also
well who says it's about you
why isn't it about you and your infant
and so your imagine your nervous system
is tuned
for the average level of danger you face
if you have a dependent infant and that
kind of sucks for you because you're
more nervous and
sensitive to pain and grief and all of
that and frustration then
would be optimal for you as an adult but
you know it's not all about you that
changed for me too when i had scarlet
i mean i was also quite ill at the time
so that's but there were the hormones
involved i think i was pretty stressed
and tolerant especially in regards to
scarlet um
until she started to be less needy right
right for the first year it was any
sound she made yeah
it like elicited a pain response i mean
it was horrible she'd go like
and you're like oh yeah your mom was
your mom was like that when when you
were
an infant we had built a
i built a bunk bed
out of wood in this small room i had in
montreal we had and we built a crib for
you right under the bed and so the room
was only about i don't know eight by ten
it was a very small room so we built
this bunk bed we only had about three
feet between the top of it and the
ceiling and then we built a crib for you
underneath and it changed it was quite
nice and it was very solid earthquake
wouldn't have taken it that was all
built out of two by fours and we built a
wall it was in what was the dining room
we built a half wall
and then built this underneath and how
big was that apartment they called it a
four and a half in in montreal and it
had a okay living bedrooms
um
really one bedroom it
it was a small two-bedroom is maybe if
you pushed it that's what it would be it
had a tiny little living room maybe ten
by ten another room adjoining the living
room that was maybe ten by ten then this
dining room that was maybe eight by ten
and then a kitchen that was somewhat
bigger l-shaped and that was the
apartment and it was a long
kind of
train car like apartment
in a poor area in montreal and anyways
that's where you were
you were uh that's where we lived when
you were born and
i'd be sleeping up on top and you would
just go you just make a tiny peep and
tammy would be
up instantly down the ladder instantly
and then she would feed you or rock you
to sleep and she was unbelievably good
at that unbelievably responsive and as a
consequence of her instantaneous
responses you almost never
got upset enough at night when you woke
up to actually wake up and so she was
amazingly responsive to to those tiny
signs of distress and so okay so and and
to flesh this out so
imagine that that's a that's a pretty
cardinal set of wiring yeah because
everyone's survival depends on it um
because peop infants are so dependent in
the first six months and so then you
think well what does the world look like
if the safety of a dependent infant is
your primary concern
and the answer to that is while your
nervous system is attuned
to optimize that
relationship because survival itself
depends on it and so then
well is everything an infant
so i think the world is divided for
women whose maternal instinct is hyper
dominant the world is divided into three
categories
infants
caretakers of infants and predators and
that's it and god help you if you're a
predator because there is if you are a
mother of an infant
there is nothing about a predator that
doesn't deserve to be destroyed and you
forget about presumption of innocence
because the the the uh the hypothesis is
going to be
prove to me you're not a predator
and you know fair enough
but it isn't obvious at all that that
ethos scales
it's not a good rule of thumb it's not a
good heuristic for picking a husband
although no predators fair enough you
know but it's not a good heuristic for
picking a husband it is not
a good heuristic
for establishing social communities
because
everyone isn't an infant everyone isn't
a caregiver and those that are neither
of those aren't all predators and so
when i looked at this mount royal
college thing and i was talking to dewal
i thought oh well we can just see this
it's like
all these faculty members are infants
except for those of them who are
predators and they all need to be
nurtured
it's like well that's freud that's
freud's edible mother that's the
devouring mother it's like
you
infants should be treated like infants
but
people who aren't infants are not
infants
and that doesn't mean they're predators
and they shouldn't all be treated like
their infants it's not helpful and it is
and the thing about it that bothers me
in particular i would say or the danger
in it in particular is that there's an
intense moralizing that goes with it
because
well there's nothing more important than
taking care of an infant fair enough
there's no job more admirable than being
a caretaker of an infant well
that's a bit trickier claim because
there's lots of ways of taking care of
people and even if you're taking care of
an infant well that requires the
provision of food for example the
provision of shelter and all sorts of
other
activities that aren't so
hyper focused on the infant but that are
equally necessary especially in complex
social environments and
then
well everyone
who isn't one of those two things is a
predator that's a just blood that's just
a bloody disaster
and so how do we know that this isn't
okay so this is my experience being
being female and i think we've had
discussions about this before because
i've got
um i've got
a lot of masculine personality traits
that just skew towards and then there
are one other women like me right yeah
but we're talking about the average
female here so i've had a hard time
understanding so we're actually talking
about the feminine temperament
okay feminine temperament yeah that
makes sense um
even more than the average female it's
more like it's like the typical feminine
temperament okay okay okay i can because
men can have this
this tilt to their thinking as well it's
less common because
the combination of personality traits
that would produce that ethos which is
likely high neuroticism and high
agreeableness is less common okay so do
you think it's not absent do you think
it's just those really high
agreeableness and high neuroticism
um i think low intelligence helps
when yeah and i i think there's a lot of
reasons
no no no specifically
my graduate student christine brophy and
i studied political correctness and
political correctness i think is an
outgrowth in part of this hyper
feminine
ethos
and i think that
well we first of all we tried to find
out if there was a set of beliefs that
cohered as politically correct or woke
yeah because that's the first question
is this just something that you know
right-wing conservatives are
hypothesizing it's like well you can
test that
statistically you can see if you have
one belief if you're more likely to have
another and then you can see which sets
of beliefs are likely to associate with
one another we found clear evidence for
the existence of
what was obviously identifiable as a
politically correct set of beliefs what
we did was take a very broad set of
beliefs and ask people about that and
then use statistics to group those
beliefs we found
a group that
i believe anyone
in our current culture would regard as
politically correct then we looked at
what predicted it
well being female predicted it over and
above agreeableness and neuroticism
which was very interesting because we
found very few
phenomena in our studies
that
where you couldn't eradicate the sex
difference by controlling for
personality that's weird yeah so
agreeableness
being female but the biggest predictor
was low verbal iq
and so you imagine that seriously woke
people are stupid no i'm saying that
people who are less verbally
sophisticated are more likely to
gravitate towards all-encompassing
simple theories because of course they
are so like kind of like
woke people maybe we're not as bright
well i think you might be able to say
the same thing about people who hold a
very
low resolution schematically
conservative viewpoint
you know where they don't deviate from
tradition at all yeah and where they're
they're not particularly sophisticated
in defending their beliefs that's not
associated with openness
that's mostly low
we didn't we that's a complicated
question because openness is associated
with verbal iq yeah if you have a low
verbal iq you're likely to be lower in
openness but it's it was complicated
because generally speaking openness
predicts liberal viewpoint but political
correctness is is not exactly it's not
exactly merely an extension of liberal
belief
but the correlation between politically
correct belief and verbal iq was
negative 0.45 which is a walloping
correlation it's it was one of the
biggest correlations we ever saw in any
study it's it's higher than the
correlation between iq and grades which
is really something because those
measures are kind of the same thing yeah
yeah so wow so
and you know there is evidence in the
university setting too that the most
politically correct disciplines are
those who are
simultaneously most dominated by females
and that have the least bright students
are those also the ones that don't
actually lead to jobs they just well
they lead to jobs now
oh yeah they've created this entire
ecosystem so that your humanities degree
matters yeah well your your your women's
studies degree let's say or yeah sorry
yeah well all humanities together yeah
no you don't want to do that you don't
want to do that but
um
and so you know this is part of a
broader
discussion that we can't have in our
culture which is
what's the evidence that the feminine
ethos scales
to
regulate families or broader communities
because we've introduced women into the
broad political discussion and we've
introduced women to every level of
social organization
but we have no evidence that women can
produce those sorts of organizations now
maybe they can and maybe it's also a
great positive that they are and i think
there's lots of evidence for that i mean
so for example it's clearly the case
that countries
where women are more educated and when
where women are granted more rights
seem to do far better economically now
whether that's because the women are
free which might be the reason or
because
the cultures that tend to be more open
to female participation are also more
open to innovative ideas of all sorts
right because it's very difficult to
distinguish between those two
we don't know but we also know that if
you educate women their children are
more motivated to pursue
higher levels of education which isn't
doesn't seem to be the case so if you
try to predict how far a child will go
in terms of their education you can use
mother iq father iq child iq and then
you can use mother education and father
education and the iq measures are
relevant
and mother's education is relevant but
father's education isn't
so and it isn't obvious why that is
maybe women are pushing on behalf of
their children yeah right oh well i got
an education you need an education yeah
maybe it may be that women who are
educated
are better at acting out the implicit
valuation of education in it like at
very early ages maybe they read more to
their children we don't know
but but so but what i'm saying is that
i'm not making a blanket case that the
introduction of women into
more sophisticated forms of social no
larger scale forms of social
organization
was like a non-starter and hopefully it
isn't because half the brain power in
the world is in the hands of women we
don't want to just leave that lying on
the table that would be a mistake for
everyone but we also don't we have no
evidence whatsoever that the maternal
ethos
scales and i think i don't think it does
i think that large-scale organizations
have to run on on conscientiousness not
on agreeableness like and there's
evidence for that too so it might
actually be negatively correlated with
agreeableness well right we've looked at
what predicts success in
complex functional organizations and the
two biggest predictors are iq because
iq is general cognitive ability and
that's just how fast and well you can
solve any problem that requires
abstraction and solving it faster is
obviously better if it's an important
problem because it's more efficient
the other predictor is conscientiousness
not agreeableness
in fact in the managerial domain there's
some evidence that agreeableness is
negatively correlated with success yeah
and i think that's because agreeable
managers get taken advantage of they
can't discipline their employees
properly and they get resentful and they
feel bad right like what happens is fire
somebody who is having a really hard
time right and then it's like oh i'll
let them stay in the company well worse
than that even i think they're prone
and i think this is the fundamental
problem with agreeableness in in some
regard as an ethos is you're completely
susceptible to
manipulation by narcissists and
psychopaths and we know this technically
we know this biologically so imagine
that you set up a game a simulation
where
everyone is cooperating you could cheat
but everyone cooperates well you can set
up a pretty stable game
that's composed of nothing but
co-operators
but if you introduce one cheater
one shark
the cheater takes everything and so and
this is this is a chronic problem for
societies is like as soon as you set up
cooperation as the norm
the desirable norm the iterable norm the
sustainable norm the productive norm
that means those who mimic
cooperation
so narcissists machiavellians
psychopaths who pretend to be
cooperative and competent can steal and
then you're faced with the problem of
okay what do you do with the free riders
and the crooks and the answer is well
you change society so that they're not
victimized it's like you are naive
beyond belief you know it's like i think
it was the mayor of seattle when antifa
established its
you know
zone of
utopia downtown it's like well it'll be
just like the summer of love which by
the way ended very badly
and that was fine until the lights went
off at night
and the criminals came to play
and you think well they're just victims
of an oppressive social organization
it's like that'll be a real good thing
to tell them when they break into your
house
and so that sort of naivety which is an
outgrowth of a kind of immature
agreeableness is seriously not helpful
when it comes to solving complex social
problems
well and one of
i suppose is the regulation of the
relationship between men and women
because
women actually don't like agreeable men
that much
now it's tough for women a because
if you have a disagreeable man
he's blunt he's not very compassionate
he's not very polite he's competitive
and so and that can degenerate into a
kind of selfish meanness and so the best
personality predictor of criminal
behavior is low agreeableness
so and and low consciousness
if you add those two together you get
something approximating psychopathy so
that's someone he doesn't care about you
at all plus he follows zero rules so
like stay away from that guy
and it isn't just that he's
misunderstood
he's a guy to stay away from and you
could add extroversion to that then
you'd get a narcissistic psychopath
and then maybe you could add
emotional stability to that and then you
get a fearless narcissistic
self-centered psychopath and then then
you have
that's a movie psychopath right yeah but
if you up the conscientiousness then you
get a ceo
right or whatever well yeah well that's
that's the okay so
what a woman needs is someone who's
disagreeable enough to keep the
psychopaths away and the criminals but
agreeable enough to share and be
reasonable and that's an unbelievable
that's a knife edge right
do they have to be agreeable enough
though or could they just be
conscientious
like okay this is fair like i can't i
think that's a value
our relationship will devolve
some no i've seen
disagreeable conscientious men try to
have relationships with agreeable women
yeah and
it's very difficult for them to bridge
the gap
because the guy is so masculine and the
woman is so feminine
that they don't really exist in the same
world
and so it's you want that you know you
don't you want a man who
it's tough it also depends to some
degree on the dangerousness of the
environment right so the more dangerous
the environment yeah maybe the more
disagreeable a man you need so it's a
really thin
needle for women to thread and that's
basically the beauty beauty and the
beast mythology right because
the woman beauty in in that story wants
a beast well why
to keep the real beasts at bay and who
are the real beasts gaston well what is
he he's a narcissist right he's a
narcissistic he borders on psychopathy
very dangerous very dangerous arrogant
egotistical self-centered and he's a
he's a parody of masculinity in some
sense
and so
beauty wants the beast because he's a
beast and he can keep gaston at bay but
he's tameable and her job and and this
is i think part of the central
female
myth of adaptation like the hero myth is
for men the hero myth is also relevant
for women but
it's it's a it's an admixture for women
because they have the beauty and the
beast thing that has to be done which i
think is primary but the hero myth which
is go confront that which frightens you
and stands in your way and thereby
prevail that's sort of like mary with
her foot on the serpent
right that's that's very much like saint
george and the dragon so there's that
element of predator defense that's
definitely part of women's makeup and
the desire to explore and intellectually
and and the desire and to and the the
ethos of courage and voluntary exposure
that's all relevant that's partly why
christ in christianity is regarded as a
universal savior he's an archetypal hero
so he's sort of like
saint george and the dragon magnified up
into a whole nother dimension of
significance but he's regarded as a
figure that's redemptive both for men
and women but then you have the figure
of mary it's like well is christ
redemptive or is mary and the answer for
women is well for the answer for both
sexes is both
but christ is regarded still as primary
for both sexes which is quite
interesting but the female situation is
more complex and so it's beauty and
beast you want to find a guy that's
tough and brave
and there's problems associated with
that he's gonna he's gonna be somewhat
uncivilized and wild and then you bring
him into a relationship and tame them
and like this is
the google
engineers who make great social
scientists when they're sort of let
loose on the data
did a wonderful analysis in a book
called a billion wicked thoughts where
they looked at female pornographic
fantasies
and so men look at look at pornography
and women read pornography and so which
is quite interesting um yeah that is
that is interesting yeah well it also
ties back to the swimsuit or the sports
illustrated issue idea yeah men or men
are very visual in their in their sexual
preference extraordinarily so but i mean
you'd have to be visual but you'd be
getting it through a different medium
right like for for a book it's not like
they just read it they read it and
visualize it right and they're
visualizing different things men are
visualizing physical features associated
fundamentally with fecundity and health
yeah youth fecality and health and that
would be clear skin plump lips
uh reddish huge skin because that's also
youthfully toned lack of wrinkles
0.68 waist to hip ratio
uh clear eyes
there's a variety of other uh cardinal
attributes symmetry is an interesting
one i read that butterflies can detect
departures from symmetry
of one part in a million in potential
mates butterflies well but you look at a
butterfly and you think man
that's pretty beautiful it's like yeah
that's sexual selection boys and girls
pretty good for the butterflies they
have that level of aesthetic capability
and their insects right one part in a
million symmetry really matters so on
the pornographic front
women
it was very comical to read this because
and i had read a fair number of uh
harlequin romances when i was a kid my
mom used to take them camping so i read
like 200 of them because they were
always lying around i just picked one up
and read it and then i had a client
whose sister
read
the more pornographic versions of
harlequin romances because they have a
more spicy yeah so i read like 10 of
those because i was curious then i
um
at least that was my excuse and then uh
because i was dreaming about pirates and
surgeons and vampires yes anyways the
google guys showed quite clearly the
pattern of female pornographic fantasy
preference and it was basically beauty
and the beast it was like tough surgeon
pirate vampire billionaire there was one
other category i can't remember uh maybe
it was corporate was it ceo it wasn't
billionaires yeah
but like hyper successful male 1
tromping around you know arrogant kind
of guy
but also someone ideally who will take
care of you even when you're feeling
sorry for something you shouldn't feel
sorry for yeah well
the the fantasy mounts
they have a couple of interactions
there's a fair bit of rejection there's
some underlying sexual tension he
realizes how beautiful she is she kind
of entices him into establishing a
relationship with him and tames her and
then you know there's some fiery sex
that goes along with that and yeah and
then so she's got herself she's got
herself her own monster and then he
serves her purposes in some sense
defense and then
generosity and and competence and
production and so and that's all
unbelievably deeply embedded and it's
rude to talk about it but like how about
50 shades of grey folks you know that
was i think did you read that i read
some of it oh i didn't read much of it
because once it was painful yeah well
and everybody read it yeah it's like i
had like everyone i knew read it
secretly yeah or not so secretly yeah
well it was a funny thing to see happen
because it was happening if i remember
correctly right at the same time as the
metoo movement it's like and that's very
that makes perfect sense psychologically
because if you get a reaction that's too
far in one direction then it calls for a
fantasy in the other direction it's like
well sex only can take place between
people of equal power whatever the hell
that means well that's that's that
sounds like a fun sexual experience well
that's part of the reason why you know
relationships between say undergraduates
and graduate students or undergraduates
and professors in universities are
hypothetically verboten which i think by
the way is a mistake because are you an
adult or not now that doesn't mean it
can't be manipulated and it doesn't mean
that there are
reasons to step forward with propriety
and i'm not a fan of promiscuity or
one-night stands or any casual sexual
relationships for that matter but
it isn't obvious to me at all who has
the upper hand in those sorts of
relationships because feminine youth and
beauty
and charm
especially allied with
personality and intelligence
is a vicious and deadly combination
there's not that's not nothing by any
stretch of the imagination it might be
the highest status
what would you say set of manifestations
that there is because i would say
generally speaking
cultures
value
young women
like ideal young women more than they
value anyone else they certainly value
the more than they value well certainly
the typical young men but maybe even
the atypical young man
what exactly is the problem with casual
relationships and how are you supposed
to find the person you need to be with
without having them
well
i think
how about abortion
that's a problem
and so
it's a minefield obviously any
discussion of abortion but one thing i
can say about abortion
that i think would
generate no
objection is you wouldn't give one to
your sister for a present
right
so whatever it is it's not desirable
and how not desirable it is is
at minimum open to question
so i don't think there's any such thing
as a casual sexual relationship
i don't believe that i've never seen any
evidence that that's the case
i think that there are
people rationalize that constantly
because they want to believe while they
want to believe that
short-term hedonistic gratification is
ethically acceptable
and i don't think it is
i think that
it trains you to treat yourself and
other people as
instrumental objects of short-term
pleasure obviously well
is that is that how you want to train
yourself how's that going to work in
your
you're going to have a long-term
relationship at some point how are you
going to train yourself for that okay so
having said that
and then you know how carefully how
carefully should we conduct ourselves in
sexual matters i would say well as
carefully as you conduct yourself in any
matter of importance and that might be
that stretches all the way up to the top
whatever the top is
you know you're going to treat the other
person as if they're a divine locus of
consciousness
or a disposable pornographic entity
well you know those are those are this
borders
okay but then you say well you have to
practice
and there's truth in that and
how do you practice and the answer is
well that's one of the central
complications of life
right to to get the balance between
individual
action and the whole domain of
sexuality and reproduction right is
perhaps there's no more difficult
question especially once you've solved
the question of do you have enough to
eat tomorrow
that would be the next one that pops up
but
i don't think there's cat i don't think
there is such a thing as casual sex
i think that's indistinguishable from
masturbation which i also don't regard
as a particularly heroic act
and so well
t-shirts masturbation not a particular
oh yeah right right right and and i
think people have that sense and i don't
think that that's culturally
instantiated because in some sense we've
done everything we can
to eradicate every last vestige of
sexual shame which i think in the final
analysis is impossible because there are
all sorts of reasons for the persistence
of sexual shame that have nothing to do
with
cultural context
and
still you know it's an
affirmative and underground activity and
the reason for that is because it's
sub-optimal for all sorts of reasons
well
how much
motivation does a young man need to
overcome his fear of rejection and
establish a relationship with a woman
and the answer to that is
we don't know
but sexual deprivation could easily
easily be part of it
because
you to do something difficult you need a
lot of motivation
you need frustration working for you you
need fear working for you you need
lust working for you you need loneliness
working for you to bind a man and woman
together especially if they're going to
produce children this is a very very
difficult thing to do successfully and
so
anything that
interferes with that is to be viewed
with extreme skepticism and that's
undoubtedly part of the reason that
shame around
hedonistic sexual activities
remains a constant despite our best
attempts to eradicate it i think i would
also say
just from my experience growing up
especially in university
it's not
like it's seen on the outside having
casual sexual relationships as this fun
thing
it's not fun
no and nobody thinks it's fun especially
women so if you're around other girls
and they're like oh yeah i hooked up
with this guy none of you guys are
actually enjoying that yeah right and i
think that's a lie that women tell each
other um why
i think because they think other people
don't care and because if you do it it
makes you feel bad enough that you're
like well i don't want to look at
that
whatever's going on there like maybe me
feeling bad is not healthy right i'm not
sure and it means there's something bad
with you yeah or there's something wrong
with you right and so it's like and it's
unpleasant enough that you're like well
i'll just you know keep going it's
already happened there's nothing i can
do about it so it might as well be okay
because what am i going to do about
what am i going to do about it if it's
not okay yeah so then
you know and i think this is pretty
common for women in university to hook
up with people right it's called hookup
culture there's tinder like it happens
but i like for anybody out there who's
who's thinking maybe i don't want to do
that
it's not fun
it doesn't make you feel good it's
really makes you really lonely right
it's not a good idea it makes you lonely
i think because what you're looking for
what you're looking for is a connection
with somebody
and you're getting this physical
connection and you're not getting any
emotional connection
and it's
right and then there's a contradiction
it's a terrible contradiction yeah and
it's well here's here's an interesting
thing i used to tell my clients is
don't do anything with anyone sexually
that you wouldn't talk to them about
it seems like well i wouldn't talk to
anybody about that it's like
but you want to get out here yeah yeah
so
that's worth thinking about you're not
intimate enough with them
to have a conscious discussion but
you're perfectly willing to blunder
stupidly into it
and then and then risk the aftermath a
lot of that's fueled by alcohol too yeah
a lot of it is like all of it you're not
going to do if we ever wanted to have a
serious conversation about
sexual impropriety on campuses for
example the first thing we'd focus on is
alcohol but we don't want to have a
serious conversation about that because
you know we don't want to have
well we don't want to have chaperoned
parties like there were in the 1950s you
know it's like well you know
having some older people around
to keep the or the drunken orgy under
control actually turns out not to be
such a bad idea especially people who um
are non-biased right are unbiased we're
just there saying well this doesn't look
like it's going well maybe i'll help
this person out yeah well instead of a
group of friends they're like no do it
like yeah right well which is a bunch of
door knobs running into each other well
that's what you get with alcohol too
yeah and alcohol is really
alcohol is a drug that really
radically
decreases people's medium to long-term
orientation right it really focuses you
on the present which makes it if it's a
good drug for you it makes it
unbelievably fun because it decreases
anxiety
and it increases
likely opiate bonding and
dopamine mediated extroversion and so
like it's cocaine heroin and
benzodiazepine rolled into one
and so
it makes you not care and for for pure
hedonism there's nothing better than not
caring
but alcohol is a catastrophe on many
fronts because of that and a huge
proportion of violent crimes
exploitative crimes rapes a huge
proportion of those are
conducted between drunk people
and so
but
i don't i don't believe that
i don't believe that there is moral
casual sex
because i don't think sex is casual i
don't think anything about it is casual
i don't think well that that's what i
think yeah fair okay so kind of on that
note uh given that people just graduated
do you have advice for recent high
school grads
i think
it's very
it's hard to overstate the importance
when you're at a point of transition
like that
so you've
you've you're done being someone that
you were a school kid you're done with
that and so that's an achievement but
it's also
the end of something it's the end of an
identity and it's a new beginning so now
you have a new beginning you have a new
beginning you don't get that many of
those in your life
if you move if you switch jobs if you
make a radical life transformation you
may have that sometimes that's
accidental it's thrust upon you that's
that's different that's harder sometimes
it's because of opportunity but maybe
you get four or five opportunities like
that in your life so they're rare
you get to be someone
new
who
who
have a vision
so when i started to puzzle this out
it was often because of talking to
clients or students who didn't know what
to do what should i do with my life i
don't know what to do with my life
fair enough and that's not a very good
question i what do i do with my life
it's like
what's the answer to everything it's not
a good question right it's too vague so
i suppose i answered this to some degree
at least initially like a conservative
person i said well what other people do
well they have an intimate relationship
they have a family
so that could be your birth family so
you can fix that up or it could be you
know your new family your kids your wife
they have friends
they have a social community that might
involve civic responsibility which is
something we're direly
lacking at the moment
you need a job
you need to take care of yourself
mentally and physically you need to
educate yourself you need to regulate
your reaction to temptation there's
eight things okay so now
you get to be whoever you want
but you have to want it
and you have to aim at it and so to do
that you have to have a vision part of
the utility of literature is the
provision of such visions negative you
know in the case of anti-heroes positive
in the case of protagonists who could
you be part of the advantage of being
educated in the humanities
is that you can draw your models from
the best history has to offer and that's
really what an education and humanity
should present you with it's like here
are the great people of history and
that's you in potential and so that
means
you can establish a new peer group you
know in some sense
my peer group
has always been
the people whose books i most admired
you know and that's a reach right
because who wants who dares to compare
himself herself to
the truly great people of the past
nietzsche for me dostoevsky jung oh and
then the classic philosophers like plato
and aristotle and kant and hume all
these
stunning people that were
brilliant beyond conception you know i
mean that's a high reach and
presumptuous in some sense but the point
of a humanities education is in large
part to surround yourself with
peers of the highest quality and so you
do that in the world of abstraction
which is and the teachers are there to
guide you through that if they only knew
that
and then you also want to do that with
your peers so one of the things you want
to ask yourself if you're graduating
from high school is well now i'm off to
do something else might be a job might
be college
it might be trade school it's like
i'm going to make new friends
what's a friend
what do i want i want someone to tell
good news to who will celebrate with me
i want someone to tell bad news to
who'll be upset that something bad
happened to me and not secretly happy i
want someone who's aiming up for me and
for them
or not or do you not want that it's like
what do you want if you're taking care
of yourself what would you want in a
relationship you need a vision for this
and we do a
staggeringly appalling job of
helping young people
even understand that that's necessary
and i know partly why i was very curious
about this because i spent a lot of time
with this future authoring program
self-authoring
part of the self-authoring suite
because we built a program to help
people make a plan and once we built the
program one of the things we found for
example was that if you gave it to young
men who were entering college
the few months before they went to
college
they were 50 percent less likely to drop
out in the first year
it's crazy for a 90-minute exercise it's
like that's just
if the world had any sense every single
college would have immediately
used that upon publication of our paper
but none of them did and that says
something is that mainly just goal
setting like what do you want well
envision that and then i think goal
setting is the wrong way to think about
it i think it's too narrow a
conceptualization i think that
you need
literally to imagine it
it's like you get to be who you want
well you need to run the story like
in detail and
if you're trying to predict whether
someone's going to commit suicide
you ask them well you know have you ever
thought about harming yourself
well you know sometimes have you ever
thought about killing yourself
well you know the thoughts crossed my
mind
do you have a plan yeah
i have a plan well
can you tell me about the plan well you
know
my dad has a
45 in the top
shelf of his desk i've seen it in there
several times the bullets are in the
drawer next door
i thought
you know i could probably
put that in my mouth in the bathroom so
i didn't make too much of a mess and
probably probably do that in the morning
that's like that's not good yeah right
that person is in danger yeah because
they've
the dream has entered their mind they've
visualized it and so i don't it's not
goal setting it's it's more like it's
much more like casting yourself in a
fully fleshed out
literary representation it's like what
is your future who are you
and
what you want to do is negotiate with
yourself it's like just imagine this is
a gospel idea right that if you knock
the door will open if you ask you will
receive if you seek you will find and no
one believes that
but i believe it's true but it depends
on what you mean by knock ask and seek
because it means
if you mean it yeah if your life depends
on it yeah that's right that's right
you're all in on it it's like you want
this what do you mean you don't kind of
want no that you don't want for like two
minutes of the day and then you get
bored right right and your right hand
wants it your left hand doesn't and no
no it doesn't mean that at all it means
you're going to make the sacrifices
necessary and you're all in on it okay
so then the question becomes
well what's worth going all in on and
the answer that is
ask yourself
you know because we know that life has
an unbearable element to it
and so
facing that forthrightly say life
suffering man and plenty of it
and so
what might make that worthwhile well
what if i had someone i really loved
who i was really attracted to that i was
really in love with that i was sexually
entranced by it's like
or what if i was that person for someone
else because that's actually a better
plan
you know what would i have to do to
myself to hypothetically be someone like
that for someone else which is a much
better way of thinking about it what if
i had kids that i loved
what if i had
friends like king arthur had friends
you know what if i was part of a
enterprise that was fundamentally
changing the world for the better it's
like would that justify it
well you have to ask yourself and if it
isn't everything you need it to be
then it's not a good vision
and
you're in an impossible situation
anyways
so why not try to do something
impossible
it's not going to be in some sense it's
not going to be any more difficult
in any real sense although it's going to
require more dedication it's not going
to be any more difficult than just
slumping along to the grave
yeah
not any less painful well yeah you have
to forego
stupid short-term hedonistic pleasure
which is
god anyone with any sense no like
cocaine it's like great for a week
you're like 15 minutes yeah
not so good iterated over 20 years
alcohol is the same way
casual sex is the same way any of those
we all know this there isn't anyone who
doesn't know these things people pretend
oh sex can just be for fun it's like
yeah right what is just for fun
name one thing
let alone something as complicated and
is entangling as sex and you also see
the job in the public culture it's like
because in the universities we have two
things going same thing violation the
principle of non-contradiction any
sexual orientation of any sort or any
practice
whatsoever
is to be
encouraged in every possible way
with no holds barred and no limitations
whatsoever
and
every single sexual interaction between
a young man and a young woman is so
dangerous
that you need a written contract before
proceeding maybe because everyone's
being encouraged to do anything well
you get one of those yeah
but not both
because both of them can't exist
simultaneously
and so
and i'm much more prone to
give credence to the danger side of it
it's like
this is no joke this is your life you're
messing around with
or someone else's life the person you're
with the baby that you produce
this is no joke
so
you think that's that anything goes it's
like
anything doesn't go in a relationship
anything doesn't go in a friendship
anything doesn't go in a business
anything doesn't go when you're alone in
the woods trying to survive
there's nowhere that anything goes and
that to to desire that is so
narcissistic and so infantile that it's
almost
unexpressable and that's our culture
yeah
okay so
what are you looking forward to in the
future this is the last question that
i'm letting you go
what are you looking forward to
being healthy yeah
not being on fire i'll settle for that
any day i'm not on fire
that's a pretty good day
so today a pretty good day
today's just fine
good thank you very much for joining me
[Music]
you